so imagine if somehow just for the
miracle of fate and weirdness
and who the knows what you end up
you have the responsibility of being the
primary water Giver for the Sisters of
Mother Teresa in Ethiopia hospitals that
house 800 people at a time worst
conditions you ever can imagine within
the depths of like a horror movie and
now you're responsible for getting the
water because they don't have water and
you didn't want this responsibility but
it was given to you by the universe what
are you supposed to do say no you say no
you know what happened yeah I know what
happens it ain't going to be good the
universe is going to smack me silly it
asks for this we do this we are humans
we stand up for each other and we do it
and we do it as good as it can possibly
be
[Applause]